what brought you back to the island I
need you out like old times
wherever just honest you know what I
like again hello Oliver do you want to
get you some back you know what you have
to tell I have no interest in this being
a fair fight
[Music]
hey everybody Deathstroke is back and
it's so awesome so I'm going to do this
video just a little bit differently
because the CW is dropping information
on flash season 4 arrow season 6 like
all the stuff that's happening next year
so there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so what I'm going to do is I'll
start with a little bit at the end of
last week's episode talk about the
footage and there's like some of the big
Easter eggs from the episode because
this week's episode was basically like a
tour de force from the flashbacks in the
island sort of trying to break Oliver
down as a human being everybody in your
orbit suffers in the flashbacks Kovar
was giving him the rocky force speech I
must break you
you're like a piece of iron you're
responsible for all of your own
suffering why don't you just end it so
we got to see yow hey come back as a
hallucination that was basically telling
him to get rid of himself you're the
problem you squandered the gift I gave
you my daughter is dead because of you
you're a complete failure but obviously
you know he's not dead because he's
alive in present day so as he's like
working his way through hallucinations
in the flashbacks it's finally the
season 1 version of Laurel that talks
him out of it come home to us you need
to come home so I thought that was a
nice touch because Katie Cassidy was
also a big thing as black siren and
present-day being an evil version of
herself that was a great part of the
story that was one of my favorite things
watching Quentin react to her for the
first time that's my baby girl this
crazy talk about earth to watching Thea
try to explain her to to him was
hilarious but you do see that look on
her face like she doesn't enjoy what
she's doing because maybe she cared
about her version of her father from
earth-2 we don't really know what
happened to quentin from earth-2 but she
says the whole
reason that she's doing this is just to
gain her freedom and to make sure that
Quentin doesn't get hurt in this big
cleansing that prometheus is doing so
just remember the Katie Cassidy as black
siren is going to be a series regular in
season six but we don't know what that
role is going to be if she's going to be
part of the Suicide Squad if she's going
to be on Team arrow I'm assuming she's
not going to be on Team arrow unless
they have some huge twist they kill off
this version of Black Canary and then
black siren takes the name Black Canary
back and becomes the new Black Canary
that would be like the craziest thing
ever but it's always possible you never
know they had that big birthday at the
beginning when they were referencing
Thea's birthday party that was the party
I think during season one where Oliver
came back and it was like really crazy
during the pilot there were so many
things in the episode that referenced
season 1 moments or literally showed
them to you like when Oliver was
flashing back we saw the Billy
wintergreen Deathstroke we saw shadow
dye the Red Death that they'd dose him
with that serum is actually a riff on
red star which is kouvaris comic book
name he's actually a comic book
character but you saw moments from
season 1 season 2 season 3 season 4
flashbacks does all of Oliver's failures
showing him his bloodlust all the times
that he killed people the times that
he's failed so Kovar breaking him down
in the way that prometheus is trying to
break him down in the present there were
a whole bunch of named drops when team
prometheus was going after team arrow
when Diggle and Felicity are driving
down the road and they make the remark
woman with two swords remember what we
did to Isabella Ravager that was
actually a great reveal because she came
up she was like where's Felicity Smoak
and Felicity just came into frame and
ran her over with the giant arrow mobile
tell me where I can find Felicity Smoak
I have been a
put a bullet in first my little fake
ever since the day but Merlin comes back
you have to remember that he is not the
legends of tomorrow Merlin anymore
because when they brought him back to
present they wiped his mind so he
doesn't remember anything about the
spear of destiny
the actor John Barrowman confirmed that
he's not coming back for season six make
whatever predictions you will about his
fate on the TV show I don't know if
they're going to kill him off because he
could always come back for Season seven
but we'll see there's going to be a
couple people that are supposed to die
in the finale and I think that's Kovar
in the flashbacks but that means that at
least one person in present-day is going
to die right before Oliver finds out
that William has been captured he tells
Prometheus you're not pulling my strings
anymore that's an iPad to the flash
where Captain Cold said no more strings
on me which is a big reference to what
he said right before he died during
season 1 of legends of tomorrow but it
was a bunch of great twists Nyssa came
back they finally go back to the island
and then they had that big lead up to
the death stroke reveal where it seems
like Oliver is on his own team arrow
doesn't know that Oliver has gotten mrs.
help
Merlin's help and they don't know about
Deathstroke in the underground prison so
if you knew the Deathstroke was coming
in the finale then you are probably just
getting crazier and crazier as mister
terrific was going on and on because
you're like oh my god they're getting
ready for they're going to reveal
Deathstroke because he does have help
and ensure enough he opens the door and
you get the slow reveal I need your help
hey kid I'm glad you came back so the
new team arrow in the flashbacks not the
captured ones are Nyssa Merlyn in now
Deathstroke so but you have like Black
Canary on black siren action here you
have pretty much everybody in a battle
royale but Prometheus also has the
League of Assassins so there's a lot of
extra bodies that he has on his side so
one of my favorite lines from that promo
is Oliver saying I have no interest in
making this a fair fight so obviously he
has to say William and then we got to
talk about what's going to happen to
some of these big characters next season
because obviously the new Bennet is on
another TV show it's not like he can be
around for the entirety of season 6 and
I am so hoping that they do not kill him
off here
way too big of a character even if he's
not going to be able to come back all
the time and they have not announced
what the roster is for that Titans TV
show in Deathstroke is just way too big
of a character for you to not have him
in the air overs depending on how the
Titans show is going to be tied to the
rest of these shows but like I said the
CW up fronts are happening right now as
we speak the revealing stuff about next
season they haven't said anything about
Titans yet so if they do I'll do a new
video about that but the really
important stuff they just announced the
schedule for the arrowverse next season
this is what it's going to be so the big
change here is that yes the CW has a
couple new TV shows but arrow is now on
Thursday nights at 9:00 p.m. after
supernatural so just more stuff
happening at the end of the week now we
have arrow on Thursday nights and we
have Inhumans and then agents of shield
on Friday nights so there's just more
stuff happening but there's still a
couple new TV shows that are coming next
season that we don't know which night
they're going to air on so as we learn
that stuff I'll just do new videos but
we got finales next week so leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner optimist 1984 please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round in this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post a DC video so click
here for brand new flash and you can
click here for my agents of shield
finale video thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you